welcome back to new rock stars black
panther wakanda forever is confirmed as
the title for the second black panther
film coming in next year
giving us our first insight into how
director ryan coogler will address the
loss of chadwick boseman
so who will be the next black panther
we're now asking
well this is inside marvel i'm eric boss
i'm here with mt
what was your reaction to seeing that
title revealing oh man
i i screamed i was like oh my god i
wasn't
expecting this but like yeah it was i'm
so excited to finally get to see
how marvel studios is going to handle
such a loss a massive loss
yeah to not only just the mcu but acting
in general it's not like chadwick
boseman was a force
so yeah i'm very hyped like how did you
feel oh i
i mean you could see my reaction that
was it's like i mean
i was blown away that should have been
like the main headline coming out of
that so they should just titled the
whole real this is
a whole separate video that justin
marvel like this is our because that is
the headline for me
so here's the deal folks in these weeks
leading up to loki mt and i are going to
be here every friday
doing a sort of mcu phase 4 preview
and we're going to do our best to answer
your biggest questions coming about the
next big upcoming marvel titles and yeah
this week really the biggest news came
from that marvel celebrates the movie
sizzle reel revealing black panther
two's title is gonna be wakanda forever
wakanda forever such a great title and
uh
in our gratitude and our excitement and
our enjoyment of this we're going to ask
a special wtf
uh what conda
but this isn't a cynical wtf this is
like a oh my god oh my god oh my god wtf
with
um so yeah empty and i actually have
some theories about wakanda forever and
what that might mean
what they're actually telling us about
who the next black panther is going to
be
uh but before we continue we want to
stay over at newrockstarsmerch.com we
are doing a special week of may the
fourth
star wars inspired shirts we actually
still have some of our zemo puppet
master design left
those are going quick but yeah you gotta
check out these star wars designs go
over to newarkstersmerch.com
uh and there you can find all the other
cool merch options we have like this
goofy high america shirt
that we sell even though there's
probably maybe six eric bosses out there
and none of them are fans of me
we're all eric boss on the inside if we
believe hard enough
yep um all right mt let's dive right
into it our first wakanda
of the day is what kind of does the
title wakanda forever
tell us about who will be the next black
panther eric yes
great question now first things first it
has been confirmed that marvel studios
does not
plan to recast the role of t'challa and
they're not gonna use vfx to weirdly
animate the character
the way star wars carrie fisher right so
neither of those options are happening
now a lot of people did
want uh there to be a recasting i
disagreed with that move
and uh so did ryan googler and kevin
feige and chadwick boston's family
they all felt that the best way to honor
bozeman's legacy was to not erase his
performance by casting a new t'challa
and not put this impossible burden on
whoever that new actor would be
to live up to that expectations to those
standards yeah uh
there's i i'm sorry that's just not the
way we should go
instead it seems like coogler's taking
the path of embracing the message of his
first film
of sharing power sharing responsibility
among all wakandans to carry that legacy
with all the heroes that t'challa
inspired in the world
because yeah this was never about one
person it was about the family the tribe
the nation the world right empty yes
yeah no i completely agree it's like
black panther it's it was not it's not
always about black panther it's all
about
the story of wakanda and that's what
makes the black panther character so
interesting
so having this wakanda forever title it
just it makes me more excited
than you know than a black panther two
would because it's just like
now we're going to get to see like what
wakanda looks like and what
potentially what it what like the
history of wakanda all that stuff
and like it seems like it's going to be
a celebration of wakanda
um and you know black people in general
but also you know obviously
t'challa chadwick boseman um and right
because we never
because of kobe we hadn't really given
him the proper tribute that i feel
um was worthy of a man and an actor of
his that has affected so many people
so wakanda forever is going to be that
moment where everyone you know is back
in the theater as
as marvel studios wants you to get hyped
about and like just be like yes
yes this is it this is we're celebrating
this amazing man
let's remind ourselves of what the words
wakanda forever mean to the mcu of
course it's the famous
rallying war cry of the wakandans it was
spoken three times
in the first black panther film first it
was by t'challa right after his victory
at warrior falls over umbaku
really to symbolize his unifying the
tribes of wakanda under his throne
and then a second time by adorama lager
guard really her final words
uh spoken to okoye as killmonger was
about to slit her throat and it was
really to show her loyalty to wakanda
and to t'challa not to kill monger who
usurped that throne
and third by nakia suited up in her dorm
milage armor
as she charged killmonger
those were the three times in black
panther but for many people it was most
memorably spoken by t'challa
when he brought the words back in
avengers infinity war during the battle
of wakanda
really his like uh charge of his forces
combined with makuu's jabari tribe as
together they faced the army of thanos
on the fields of wakanda
[Music]
yeah oh such a great moment i mean the
whole crowd erupted when that happened
i'll never forget that so really if you
think about it what kind of forever is
the phrase shared by all wakandans it
was spoken by t'challa to share
a sense of common patriotism with his
wakandan family
and this tells us that the second black
panther film could really be a story
about wakanda as a society
not just a person who wears the black
panther suit but
however let's also remember wakanda
forever is also a phrase associated with
three
characters in t'challa's orbit nakia
okoye
and mbaku and i believe these three are
really our top candidates for
successor of the black panther mantle
now yes
shari's name has been floated and of
course of course we can all see a future
in which cherie dons that suit
but empty i want to know what you think
about this for me not yet just because
right now
i think she's more valuable as like the
genius engineer
and comic relief of this franchise as
opposed to
like the stoic warrior who wears it
herself i think it would take away
everything we like about her right now
to just force her into that role
i think over time she'll get there
though yeah no i think exactly that i
think that
in order for us to really see you know a
shuri black panther
i think she has to earn it i think we
have to see her go through that training
of like all right like
yeah maybe i'm not black panther now but
like i just i'm gonna you know
punch real good like do some you know
push-ups and all that stuff and like you
know
really get into the uh the black panther
um training and all that stuff so she
could be ready to potentially take the
mantle but to just do it right away
and just be like all right now sure it's
a black panther now it really wouldn't
make sense for where shuri is
currently at at the moment right so you
know i think that you know like you said
nakia okoye and baku are amazing
candidates and probably the three most
likely um to carry on the the mantle
now it was uh nakia actress lupita
nyong'o who of these three let's face it
is the biggest star she's won an oscar
all three of them are great though and i
would say uh
uh deny guerrera and um winston duke
definitely had more action
uh in their roles that they played but
yeah it was lucy didn't yango who spoke
most recently about what coogler's plan
was she said
quote coogler's idea the way in which
she has reshaped the second movie is so
respectful of the loss we've all
experienced as a cast
and as a world so it feels spiritually
and emotionally correct to do this
and hopefully what i do look forward to
is getting back together and honoring
what chadwick started with us
and holding his light through it because
he left us
with a lot of light and that we're still
going to be bathing in
what a great quote yeah one thing i want
us all to remember is that in that first
black panther film it's how important
color was to ryan coogler in all
definitions of that word
uh but specifically his costume choices
and he worked with designer ruth e
carter
who is amazing she won one of the film's
oscars for her work on this film
and uh really there was this one choice
that carter and coogler made
about the uh about the way they would
dress three characters t'challa akoya
and nakia
in black and red and green the colors of
the pan-african flag
yes uh such a great moment when they're
walking through korea right
yeah so here's my theory i think the
mantle of black panther will succeed
from one hero t'challa to a team
of three heroes and their armor
color schemes are going to reflect those
three colors
nakia and green okoye indoor melange red
and baku the runner up to t'challa at
warrior falls who later joined his rival
in defending wakanda against thanos
mbaku
in black and i believe that shuri will
have designed these three suits so that
they only work when the three are
working together
so that way the will of t'challa and the
light of chadwick
could live on in the most emotionally
resonant way really giving new meaning
to
wakanda forever bro i love that so much
that's such a good idea like three black
panthers are like
like so like oh man that is such a fun
way to tackle that
i love it i love it i love it it's it's
it's a shared identity
uh and that doesn't mean a bright green
uh suit it could be like black just with
uh you know green accents in it could be
black with red accents in it yeah and
then black with purple accents in it
and really it gives any of the three a
chance to take over the mantle for a
black panther three
you know yeah uh or none of them and
then we just completely wipe the slate
clean and then we bring in a new person
shuri
or a child or you know someone who steps
into it um
but i think for right now we shouldn't
give it to give that burden to one
individual
we should share it to three individuals
who have to work together i think that's
what shuri would want it would
empower her to continue to make sure her
brother's will is carried on
yeah i oh man that would be so tight to
see just
and like honestly in my head like
because i'm like a huge nerd i'm like
that would make a great video game
like yeah so fun for certain
just fight everyone but like no for like
that would be such a
really unique take on the black panther
mantle
and it would just it would be so
interesting to see how the people of
wakanda
um respond to something like this
because there's always
been traditionally one black panther
title
so for for it to go from one to three
it would just be so just so interesting
to see if people would reject that
or yeah you know no matter what you do
it's going to be controversial with some
fans right
like there's going to be people who say
the only way to honor chadwick boseman
is to recast and keep the character
alive you know
there's going to be people who are in
one specific camp it says it has to be
shuri or it has to be a koi it has to be
mbaku
um i don't want them to forget about
mbaku that's my fear
is that like he'll just be regulated to
this uh rival who always stays up in
the mountains but he's such a cool
character wants to do such a good actor
he and leticia wright went to college
together and they're really good friends
so for them to be able to build that
chemistry together for all these actors
to continue to have to have to work
together
i think is amazing uh and i hope that's
uh i'm not saying ryan coogler has to do
this it's his movie he can do whatever
he wants i'm not going to gatekeep this
you got to do this right yeah yeah uh i
just think that's the safest way forward
you know it's that way you can satisfy
everybody i think i think that's a
really great idea man like i am all for
this though i do have
an idea of what will come forever yeah
what ended up becoming
i mean we could because wakanda's been
around for so long
we could just see like you know what
khan the history of wakanda or like the
different black panthers throughout the
years
like maybe potentially because we're
getting time travel shenanigans
what if we get like a past black panther
like
as the new black panther it's like
michelle it's like i'm here again
kind of like a reverse captain america
type deal it's like oh now i love the
future and like this is really weird
um but yeah you wouldn't even need time
travel just to go do a period piece of
like yeah
chaka's story you know you only have to
go one generation back
i mean that would be dope i would love
to see like the history the early days
of past black panthers and that way
you wouldn't have to worry about the
present battles you could just tell yeah
just do it just a different
time period story it would be super dope
but like
yeah just because like i don't think
that would happen if we were just doing
that story because just because it's
called wakanda forever
so like you know it would we're probably
gonna get like a more like wakanda
focused like
i don't know modern story but like man
it would be really cool to just to see
like you know
have it be like almost like an anthology
um yeah
thing where it's like all right he's the
first black panther he was like the i
don't know the 16th
black black panther abraham lincoln and
what you're tapping into mt
is i think like we're we've been talking
about what the legacy
who the legacy character of black
panther is going to be who the title is
going to go to
which i think is the question on
everyone's mind but really the title of
wakanda forever makes me think this is
going to be a story about a setting
about a country
about a society you know and there are a
lot of questions we have about
the country of wakanda and its history
and its role
in the world now as really like the
world superpower they have the most
advanced everything
you know and i think it's a fascinating
culture
that was my favorite thing about the
black panther film uh it also won an
oscar for its production design and just
the world of it like
i want they they have the avengers
campus at disneyland i want them to make
a wakanda i want to visit a wakanda walk
the streets of wakanda oh my
god it's amazing it would be so fire
it would make so much money if they did
that so much money oh my god
why haven't they done that smh it's
maybe they're waiting maybe they're
waiting but
uh yeah either way i think that this
next movie
is going to explore the society
structure of
wakanda and its role in history because
kind of like the eternals
this is a group of advanced folks who
have been around for a while but have
decided to stay out of certain battles
and not fight every battle
so yeah i want to see those debates
happen like why did they decide to stay
out of certain battles who made those
decisions what were the debates behind
the scenes what were the wars fought
behind the scenes
yes um and what were things that they
did intervene in that
the rest of the world just didn't know
about because they fixed the problem
there's a lot of oh man there's so many
different opportunities and like there's
so much potential for this series
for it to be just like completely game
changing or like just
like you said like revealing like secret
parts of how
wakanda has been secretly shaping the
world yeah ryan coogler is the guy to do
this like he fully understands the
tanehisi coats
uh approach of like the afrofuturist
revision of
like this character and the
forward-looking
uh kind of sci-fi approach that still
embraces the racial roots of the
character
uh coogler gets it i mean i'm so excited
to see what this guy comes up with
like coogler was the best man for the
job for black panther one and like he's
gonna kick ass in this new sequel
so so uh we're gonna talk more we have
more questions obviously that we're
gonna
uh address about this about this film uh
but before we continue
uh big thanks from our sponsor manscaped
big announcement the manscaped
engineering team has created the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer and it is
available in the usa and canada
join over 2 million men worldwide who
trust manscaped with this exclusive
offer 20
off and free worldwide shipping with the
code marvel manscape.com
the craftsmanship and details on the 4.0
are next level their advanced ceramic
blade and skin safe technology
are both so good it's kind of like stark
industries decided to get into the pube
trimming biz
it's not that far outside the realm of
possibility tony did have a very
manicured goatee so you can only imagine
what you know
don't imagine that i'm sorry the
lawnmower 4.0 has a travel lock a 4000k
led spotlight and it allows you to
customize your trim with four guard
lengths the optimized lawnmower 4.0
trimmer is waterproof so you can groom
in the shower and it's got wireless
charging
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code marvel at manscape.com
your balls will thank you trademark get
20 off in free shipping with the code
marvel
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use the
code marvel
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscape
we also want to thank our friends at
helix sleep for sponsoring this episode
whether you're bunking up in wakanda or
wisconsin
you want to be sleeping on a mattress
designed to fit you
and your body helix sleep has a quiz
that matches your body type and your
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
i took the quiz and got matched with the
dusk lux helix mattress because i wanted
a medium firm mattress with lumbar
support that sleeps cool
i sleep so good on my helix mattress the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free
and you never need to go to a mattress
store again they were awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine just go to
helix leap.com
inside marvel for their two minute sleep
quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our audience at helix
sleep dot com slash
inside marvel that's helix sleep dot com
slash inside marvel for up to two
hundred dollars off and two free pillows
and we want to thank our friends at
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode so
bluechu has a unique online service that
delivers these same active ingredients
as viagra in cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days their licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient in strength and if
you hate swallowing pills good news blue
chew is
chewable just like it says in the name
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
the promo code inside marvel at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code
insidemarvel
to receive your first month for free and
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
show
all right mt let's move on to our next
wtf here
do you think bucky could appear in black
panther wakanda forever as the white
wolf
that's a really good question i think
yes yeah just because of that that last
line that i o gives bucky at the end of
helping with well
at the end of her appearance in falcon
the winter soldier she was like just
stay
scarce don't come back to wakanda and
so and because bucky had has i mean
presumably played a
big role in wakandan society during that
time
um between the uh
i'm sorry what like liking civil war in
infinity war um
you know it makes sense for him to come
back just to at least check up on people
and then for them to probably enlist his
help because
of the uh passing of their black panther
i'm assuming that t'challa is dead in
the mcu
um right so they might ask him for his
help or he might show up at the funeral
i mean i would hope so i mean tyler did
so much for him
so you know he's got to show up then but
like i don't know what do you think
do you think he's gonna actually um yeah
i i do i at least hope he does because
as you've been saying mt i feel like
they've set up all this stuff and then
what other story will it be if not in
this one and uh
a title like wakanda forever just gets
like my brain worrying into thinking
like
this is a battle for the existence of
wakanda itself because if you think how
the first movie ended
it was kind of this fear of like we're
opening up our existence to the world
we're addressing the u.n they
know about us now uh and then that
immediately led to
infinity war the stakes of that were
okay now the avengers know to hide
vision here and thanos knows where we
are
et cetera et cetera um but i think the
fear now is that there can be other
rival nations who
want what wakanda has whether that's the
united states
whether that's nations like latvia
or atlantis you know uh i want to see
the map expanding
and i think it's going to be all hands
on deck to defend
wakanda now and um they're going to need
everybody they're going to need their
full
door milage all the tribes are going to
have to unite and i think they're going
to need their white wolf and the war
dogs you know
yeah i think that's yeah the people are
definitely going to have
their sights on wakanda now especially
after um
t'challa's announcement at the end of
the black panther one
um it's it's it's just inevitable it is
something that the wakandan nation has
dealt with
throughout its entire history in the
comics like people that find out
that wakanda is the shangri-la of just
like
of money potential money with vibranium
like they just try to get it
um we see it with claw we see it with um
you know the early
in the early days of wakanda like
they've they've
surprised a lot of would-be conquerors
with their high-tech
um solutions like way way back in the
day and it's so so cool to see them kick
ass
um like futuristic like that no but uh
yeah i
i think in addition to bucky it'd be
great to see you know some other
avengers show up it doesn't have to be
their story but
empty and i have this like hope that
steve rogers old man
steve rogers could be retired somewhere
in wakanda just he's like a hawaiian
shirt
a major just old man tourist like oh
this is mighty nice wow
he's like petting the rhino he's like
are you peggy
and they're like no no steve
[Music]
[Laughter]
man old steve rogers talking to animals
is it's just a series mt and i are gonna
spin off and do that
that would be so funny someone needs to
make a comic strip
of just old man steve rogers is doing
random [ __ ] trying to slow dance with a
rhino
it's been no longer
just in case people don't understand
what i'm talking about oh my god
oh my god um oh here's another uh wtf
question
um and we've talked about this before do
you think black panther wakanda forever
could take place during the blip because
that would be one way they could get
around chadwick boseman's absence
um is there any chance that could be the
case what do you think that
is a really good um question in point
because like i i i always thought like
because like at the end of uh
end game we we have that shot of the
city of wakanda
and it's just like what happened during
those five years
right um because there wasn't a king so
like i feel like that's definitely going
to be covered
in some degree in the show um i hope
that it doesn't take place during the
blip because i do want to see
how they um how they take the like a
permanent
um t'challa death um
so but i think we're gonna see like all
the interesting
power vacuum type stuff that happened
during the blip but what do you think do
you think it's gonna take place
well i think for the full movie to take
place during the blip it would have to
just be a smaller stake story because we
know what the global stakes are on the
other side of the blip right we know
you know we know where uh you know as
soon as hulk snaps everyone back
presumably you're gonna have some scene
where you know uh the characters who've
lived from wakanda would
reanimate and and then you couldn't
really do that without having to
do this weird vfx stuff with chadwick
boson which i don't think anyone wants
to see um
so it would have to be like kind of a
smaller side story of just like how the
survivors of wakanda got by well okoye
was up to what i believe in baku was up
to
you know um which could be a fascinating
story i'd rather that be
maybe brought up as a subplot in uh
black panther what kind of forever story
that takes place on the other side of
the blip
um as you said empty to kind of move
forward from it
um but yeah a prelude comic set during
the blip would be interesting
i have to open it it's like don't go
anywhere book i'm watching you
the book moved i saw that book move it's
one of those harry potter howler things
oh no that's a letter right ron weasley
[Laughter]
ron weasley i gotta re-watch those
movies it's been so long
careful not all parts of it age well
the acting of the children is
bad yeah i mean i remember them being
better than they were
but yeah when i was a kid i was like
these kids are just amazing actors so
good
this is the peak of acting now i'm just
like oh boy uh
now that we've had like uh stranger
things in it
which is like it's like oh child actors
can actually be
pretty good um yeah but they just needed
a kid that looked good in glasses like
oh you look like harry potter
come on in i think they have all been
great after the harry potter franchise
like uh
dana radcliffe's work post harry potter
pretty good yeah
he's a great actor even rupert grant has
shown up in some stuff not bad
but during those movies big learning
curve man i'm gonna get some hate mail
for this
i'll just say anything negative about
harry potter though you like harry
potter it's just
they only yeah sometimes it's just hard
to go back like to things in general
like especially like video games like
going back to play i remember playing um
arkham knight no yeah
yeah going back it's just like oh it's
so hard to just because
things progress and people get better
and like that's just how time works so
like yeah
it's just it's hard to watch earlier
performances of
a lot of people's careers and and
fairness to those kids in the harry
potter movies their co-stars
are the best actors in yes
so if you have like maggie smith and
rick
you have alan rickman who you're doing a
scene with yeah you're going to get a
little overshadowed
but yeah with that ginger kid i mean
he's not alan rickman but i guess right
yeah yeah for sure all right uh before
we move on uh one more
sponsor we want to thank our friends at
best spoke post so thank you bespoke
post for sponsoring this episode uh
bespoke post has a new lineup of
essential box of awesome collections for
guys guaranteed to upgrade your life
the retreat box comes with a cool
hammock and the boardwalk box
comes with some fancy flip-flop sandals
to get you ready for some summery
adventures
whether you're out taming the wilderness
or taking your home bar to
pro level heights bespoke post only
sends guys the best stuff every month no
matter what you're into box of awesome
has you covered from style and grooming
goods to bar wear cooking tools and
outdoor gear box of awesomeness
collections for every part of your life
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
the coast and flight boxes are the new
ones that look really really cool
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time each box only
costs 45
but has over 70 worth of gear inside get
20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code marvel
at checkout that's box of awesome dot
com code marvel for 20
off your first box all right uh one
final what kind of
uh mt a lot of people are asking this do
we think
it could be possible that killmonger
could return and black panther
wakanda forever that is a really good
question and i keep going back and forth
with this one
because like as much as i love
killmonger dog michael b jordan killed
the roll
no pun intended yeah um but you know
then
t'challa killed him so like it's i i
would love to see
more killmonger in the form of like
flashbacks
because like he had a really extensive
history with like you know
being a um a mercenary wasn't mercenary
or an awkward yeah
well he was yeah he was military and
then he became a mercenary after that
and like so like there's a lot of
opportunities like
like maybe like doing a flashback with
john walker maybe we can see
oh john had a run in with um with killer
monger or something like that
but so like to bring characters back
from the dead
you have to have a really good reason
and i just feel like
killmonger's last words were so powerful
and
it was just his whole i think we just
need to let it go
um yeah because like you know as we
could always just re-watch black panther
if we want to see kill monger
but i i don't think that um kevin feige
is going to bring him back but what do
you think
yeah i agree with you i think michael b
jordan's got all other kinds of projects
that he's working on
and i'm excited to see what he does next
he has been one of the best villains of
the mcu
so i think we want to see him come back
in more ways
um but yeah he is uh i the way that's
been theorized before is that you know
like the
uh atlanteans with neymar could have
found his body if he was buried at sea
and then like
you know they could have resurrected him
for like uh
uh kind of a strike against wakanda but
that would get
super insane but like i don't
know why you need to have uh a name or
or an atlantis versus wakanda story and
also have killmonger there it kind of
feels like a hat on a hat
in a way i don't think it seems like
very uncharacteristic for the atlanteans
to do anyway just
because like they they sort of view
themselves as better well
they don't view themselves as better
than everyone else but they're not going
to be like oh we need this human being
right to help us win they they're just
gonna be like we can just do it
ourselves we don't need this guy
right this is just more littering in the
ocean that we're pissed about
yeah the the harder part about how
they're gonna
strike them is like i believe wakanda is
an inland country it
does have a body of water connected to
it but it's not like ocean connected
you know so like it would have to be
wakanda has like a secondary colony
somewhere in antarctica or something
like that or somewhere else and then
through that exploration and a lot of
people point to okoye's line about the
undersea earthquakes and end game and
that could be what that was a reference
to
uh that there's some kind of rivalry
between atlantis and wakanda there
but that's just one of many little lines
in end game that we have in our memory
bank of like this could mean this
i don't think the russo's intended it
for it to be that i think they like to
play coy and be like maybe
i like i think that like kevin feige
just loves to put little stuff like that
just
just to like bait us into making ideas
so we can be like
this is a good idea put us on the
payroll feige we will
we will do all this work for you and
then you give these scripts to
your great writers or to us i i can i've
written movie names before
if i had to write a script i think i'd
ask for uh a meager fee
for that but i i could i would do it for
half whatever you paid uh eminem you
know those guys
i don't need listen i just paid me in
one of your hats kevin just give me one
of your hats
maybe pour some cereal in it's like
energy yeah
that's that's all i want
well uh for all of you uh joining us
today let us know in the comments below
what you want to see from black panther
wakanda forever what do you think this
title means
uh but that is it for this episode of
inside marvel mt and i are going to be
back
every friday covering all the biggest
marvel news over these next few weeks as
we wait for loki in early june and at
that point
hold on to your butts we're gonna go hog
wild on that show
because it is uh ripe for me and empty
yeah we are picking apart he gonna go
low-key
oh baby oh baby
all right stay tuned for that and be
sure to follow
mt at mastertainment follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast subscribe to us here on new
rockstars
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you next week bye
[Music]
foreign